the NIH active six trial where they had
to do something which is considered a
never event which is changing the
primary outcome in the middle of the
trial
and they changed it right they were
looking at a difference in illness I
think symptoms severity
um at day 14. that was the original
protocol which makes sense for violin
unless you want to see who gets better
by day 14. and in the middle of the
trial without prevailing any data for
why they did it they switch it to now we
want to compare how people are feeling
at day 28. and in the actual paper you
see that at day 14 there's a profoundly
statistically significant difference in
favor of ivermectin so if your trial is
there and you're you know Farmers
running these agencies in these trials
suddenly your researchers are telling
you uh Houston we got a problem here we
have a profoundly statistically
significant benefit that we've
identified at day 14. what are we going
to do
the answer
let's change the endpoint to day 28
where that's statistically significant
by the way it's still beneficial there
just wasn't statistically significant
yeah it wasn't statistically significant
which somehow you know because the Press
is undereducated with respect to science
yep journalists will translate into no
effect which is absolutely and
completely unjustified interpretation
um but
you know I I have been
persuaded by my own scientific Journey
that the philosophy of Science Matters
tremendously and almost nobody is
educated in it because it's boring and
seems like a different field and all of
that and this is a case where
the
the alteration the moving of the goal
posts in the middle of the study is
it renders the entire exercise
completely scientifically invalid
invalid Brad if I did that in a try
let's say I did a study imagine the the
the the speed of the rejection from the
journal when I actually submit my paper
and they say they see that I changed my
endpoint moved the goal post in the
middle of connecting the study they
would say I'm sorry we can't publish
this you've you've committed a
scientific you know a trial a trial
wrong like these these invalidate I'm
sorry Dr Corey this invalidates whatever
you found so the level of evidence it
invalidates it at the level of behavior
it's fraud yep right you are
the thing that makes science work
is the directionality of the observation
right you have a pattern
You observe it you hypothesize a
possible explanation you formulate a
test based on the predictions and then
you run the test it has to go in that
order or there's no science in it
if you knowingly take the prediction and
you modify it to match the data
you have taken something that is
anti-scientific and you has Dre you have
dressed it as if it was science which is
not only is there no information in your
study because we don't know where else
you did that but the intent
evident in your modifying you're moving
the goal posts mid-study
is to deceive to lead people to believe
that the evidence says one thing rather
than what it actually said right you are
required even if you think your study
uh found sampling error right to the
extent that you are interested in
publishing this study you have to
publish what it actually found relative
to the actual predictions which in this
case come in the form of this particular
measure That Was Then altered mid study
that's fraud you describe the scientific
method right and you talked about then
tested and here there's some rules on
how you test things right you come up
with a study design and you say I'm
going to compare these two things in
this way
and that's what you got to stick to
right but here here I want to go a
little further right so you you call
that first of all it's anti-science it
invalidates the study I like how you
call that the behavior is fraud right
the ACT is anti-science and invalidating
the behavior is fraud but let's go
further there that study
sailed
to publication in the Journal of the
American Medical Association which is
literally I think it's number two or
number three on the highest impact
medical journals in the world
published that study
where they move where they change the
end point in the middle I mean and there
was really very little mention of it
it's not even a limitation and of course
no one talks about in the media no one's
like oh Jama just published a study but
they moved the goal post in the middle
and and what's even more crazy right and
I I'm sure you've seen the table right
because Alex Mourinho did such good work
on on dissecting these trials his work
is unparalleled um in the stuff that
he's done and he's not even a physician
I'm using polymath he's brilliant but I
mean I I would the comprehensiveness and
detail of the work that he did I mean I
learned a lot about I learned way more
Shenanigans in these trials than even I
could pick up I've heard Alex right and
but you know Alex you know highlighted
the table that's published in the actual
so it's so Brazen where they show the
difference at day seven day 14 and day
28 and you can see the statistical City
you see that it was highly statistical
significant Days Seven day 14 and then
whoops just falls under statistical
seven day 20. so it's screaming from the
paper
in the journal American Medical
Association there's no discussion of it
and so that that's gonna that that to me
would be like exhibit a in a courtroom
of evidence that Pharma runs these
journals
a hundred percent and I would just point
out like let's say
all right
you've recovered from covid
and you go to the doctor and the doctor
says all right let's get you vaccinated
right so let's suppose you know what it
means that you've recovered from covet
and you realize hey Doc how much do you
know about the safety of these novel
vaccines and
what happened to natural immunity we
know that that's the best immunity
what's more if I look at these vaccines
there's no way it could possibly compete
because the antigenic choice is so
narrow and the antigen is
uh of a variant that's no longer
circulating so you you hear okay your
doctor is advising you to get a shot
that can't possibly be safe
and cannot possibly compete with the
immunity that you've already got and the
same doctor is telling you
um yeah if you get covid or you're
exposed to somebody who has it
Ivermectin doesn't work at the point
that you discover that your doctor is
in some way Downstream of some
Distortion that has caused them not to
look out for your best interests with
respect to these so-called vaccines at
the point you know that they're
needlessly exposing you to the risks of
a novel therapy
when that same doctor tells you that
actually repurposed drugs are not
effective
then you should wonder whether the very
same distorting influence has caused
them to miscall that one as well and
what I see almost across the board
is people assuming that the embarrassing
Revelations surrounding the so-called
vaccine campaign are the limit of what
happened for some reason the
sophisticated position is yes but
Ivermectin didn't work which uh is
obviously not like that was the ceiling
of the corruption and fraud was the
vaccines right and they they don't see
how much further and deeper it went
right
um and I don't I don't think they
understand
well I mean this is really the core
issue yeah
um they do not understand
what the pandemic would have looked like
if
we had played differently with respect
to repurposed drugs and vitamin D
right if we had applied those things
um what would you know look through
pharma's eyes yeah at the level of how
profitable this would have been it was
spectacularly profitable profitable as
it went down how profitable would it
have been if we went on a campaign to
correct people's vitamin D deficiencies
and had applied Ivermectin as a
prophylactic when people were exposed to
covid and then treated them with
iromectin and hydroxychloroquine if they
came down with covid what would the
pandemic have looked I feel like I want
to raise my hand and be like call on me
I want to answer that you know all right
I mean Brett we know the answer right it
would have obliterated those massive
marketplaces that opened up with this
pandemic I mean overnight you had a
Marketplace and north of 100 billion
dollars right uh for the pricey patented
Pharmaceuticals and the vaccines I mean
first of all obliterate that market
that's one thing that's that was what
they were trying to avoid but we know it
would have changed the face of the
pandemic I mean we've seen it in places
that that use repurposed drugs I mean it
was a very that you didn't have
hospitals filling you would have very
few hospitalizations very few deaths
very little morbidity it would have it
would have changed the entire experience
of this pandemic and it would have saved
millions of lives
[Music]
oh